so let's add six over two x squared
minus seven to negative three x minus
eight over two x squared minus seven and
like always pause the video and try to
work it out before i do
well when you look at this we have these
two rational expressions and we have the
same denominator 2x squared minus 7. so
you could say we have 6 2x squared minus
7 and then we have negative 3x minus 8
2x squared minus 7 is one way to think
about it so if you have the same
denominator this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
our denominator is going to be 2x
squared minus 7
x squared minus 7 and then we just add
the numerators so it's going to be 6
plus
negative 3x
minus 8. and so if we want to simplify
this a little bit we'd recognize that we
could add these two constant terms the 6
and the negative 8. 6 plus negative 8 is
going to be negative 2 so it's going to
be negative 2 and then adding a negative
3x that's the same thing as subtracting
3x so negative 2 minus 3x
all of that over
all of that in that same blue color
x squared
minus 7. and we're done we've just added
these two rational expressions
let's do another example
so here we want to subtract one rational
expression from another so see if you
can figure that out
well once again both of these rational
expressions have the exact same
denominator the denominator for both of
them is 14x squared minus 9 14x squared
minus 9. so the denominator of the
difference i guess we can call it that
is going to be
14x squared minus 9.
so 14 x squared minus 9 did i say 4x
squared before 14x squared minus 9.
that's the denominator both of them so
that's going to be the denominator of
our answer right over here
and so
we can just subtract the numerators so
we're going to have 9
x squared
plus 3
minus
minus all of this business
minus negative 3
x squared plus 5
and so we can distribute the negative
sign this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 9
x squared plus 3
and then
if you distribute the negative sign
the negative of negative 3x squared is
going to be plus
3 x squared and then the negative of
positive 5 is going to be negative 5. so
we're going to subtract 5 from that and
all of that is going to be over 14x
squared minus 9.
14x squared minus 9.
and so in the numerator we can do some
simplification we have 9x squared
plus 3x squared so that's going to be
equal to 12x squared
and then
we have
plus negative 5 or we could say 3 minus
5 so that's going to be negative 2
and all of that is going to be over
14 x squared minus 9.
14 x squared
minus 9. and we're all done we have just
subtracted and we could think about is
there any way to simplify this more are
there any common factors but these both
could be considered differences of
squares but they're going to be
differences of squares of
of different things so they're not going
to have common factors so this is about
as simple as we can get